ouais ouais ouais
ouais
ouais ouais je me dois un boulot une minute
Cole ouais ouais maro perak PA ouais
bon
coup d'appel les voitures
rendent ton argent 50c paire de cancer
39 un confondre quelque chose sur cet eby est à
propos de Junior je suis le chef a vaincu une
noix de cajou Cooper  commentaires plus faciles à faire
2013 un comme coca-cola la route
Oh
ça va ouais
- laissez-moi voir le compliment de plaisir pendant que vous
planifiez le NEPA que mes parents même
30 ou 50 congés sabbatiques
parfois vous allez caramel 2008 aussi chère
Marcia Marcia muth tout seul
alors  désolé papa un bébé
te rend pipi 39 aujourd'hui je fais honte à la banque de croire
qu'il a raison
tout va bien
Oh est-ce
que
mon père t'a vu jouer tu es
mort en couple
mon père
dernièrement ça
II
Oh
Cody
mec
il sait tout abandonner les médias
Oh
tu me dois toujours des excuses
dans le plat de cornichons
Oh
laisser tomber
les couteaux